this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
army's museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode he's going to be checking
out the armory of the milsim shooter
armor 3 a game that he was quite
impressed with this is probably the most
detailed in-game model of an akm i have
ever seen if there are any other games
guns and mechanics that you guys want to
see jonathan break down let us know in
the comment section below be sure to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and if you'd like to help out the royal
iron muse museum and continue to support
jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right over
to jonathan
got a quite a nice representation of the
g36 within the limitations of the
graphics engine of course it's quite
well done the i know do you notice that
the ammunition is quite nicely there's
attention to detail there you can see
that there's a defined i don't know if
it's the cannula or or the lacquer or
something but like you can see the
bullet is a separate entity to the
cartridge case normally ammunition is an
afterthought in games especially uh
games a few years old it's something you
don't see for very long gets overlooked
and i think this being quite a high
intensity detail milsim style game i
think that's why they've represented the
ammunition the way they have cartridge
cases though looked a little bit
procedural in the sense of they don't
seem to be coming out organically due to
that relationship between extractor and
ejector cartridge cases tend to spin
well they do spin out but here they do
look a bit old-school video game where
they come out perfectly perpendicular to
the gun as usual i'm being extremely
picky here because that's kind of my job
i've heard quite a lot of good things
about sniping in the armor games the way
it's set up to allow for the various
factors that you have to consider the
rifles implemented pretty well for its
native role of proper sniping at long
distance seems to behave as it ought to
something i noticed there though in
using it close up as you might have to
if you're ambushed the weapon model
doesn't move when it's being operated
now that's completely to be expected if
it's if you're in the prone position the
bipod's deployed the thing is
the butt is in your shoulder then you're
not going to see any movement of the
rifle but if you're holding it at a sort
of low ready looking over the sights as
you'd have to do if you were shooting at
this close distance then inevitably the
the gun is going to move some as you
[ __ ] it this is a milsim type game but i
expect every little detail of military
detail to be there but i don't
necessarily expect naturalistic physics
of how everything moves around if that
makes sense so i'm not put off if player
characters rotate on the spot without
moving their feet for example and the
same would apply to this weapon model it
looks as it should it looks reasonably
weathered and camouflaged yeah so the
third person view reveals a bit of a
quirk when the weapon is loaded the
player is doing what you'd expect
pushing forward locking the bolt into
position but in firing between shots
there doesn't appear to be any actual
bolt cycling going on the bolt kind of
just drifts out and goes back into
battery on its own that's clearly not
deliberate i'm guessing that with a an
expansive detailed simulation game like
this it's just something that's been
overlooked
the israeli tavor
21 version in the game is almost the
same or rather this is almost the same
as the version in the game the only
difference the optical sight
arrangements
here so
as introduced to the israeli defense
force it looked like this and you had
these flip up
rear iron sights which you can actually
flip up front and rear iron sights
co-witness through the optical sight so
the aperture in the front post coincide
with the red dot so if this breaks or
it's
too dark and the daylight powered scope
isn't working then you can use the the
iron sights on the gun
what we see here is the effectively the
export version where that's been
replaced by a strip of picatinny rail
and the rear sight arrangements have
changed so that they're part of this new
system so this this whole section here
changed other than that this is as
introduced the thing that stuck out for
me though is the grenade launcher on
this thing there is an iwi underbarrel
grenade launcher module for the tavor
it's not this this looks basically
identical to the fn underbarrel grenade
launcher for that's fitted for the f2000
or the scar kind of weird to see one
company's grenade launcher on another at
this point we also see a bit of a quirk
of i think the game in that that grenade
launcher has a big ring trigger double
action mechanism and you pull on that
ring trigger to fire it that's not
what's happening in the clip effectively
the player is switching between the
firearm and the grenade launcher and
firing the grey launcher off the rifle's
trigger which is almost unheard of other
than for designed bespoke solutions like
the oicw where you've built that in from
the outset and it's electro electrically
linked generally speaking the same
trigger for
a destructive device effectively and a
rifle is a bad idea for safety
reasons
okay i gather this game is set some
years some decades into the future so we
would expect to see some high-tech types
and this thing certainly is this is the
general dynamics take on the lightweight
medium machine gun which is one of these
experimental us projects that's still
ongoing now i'm looking here at a first
person view we've got
we've got the gun we've got the optic
all looks very good and then we've got
the ammunition always pleasing to see
actual case head markings depicted even
if it's a flat texture and if my screen
was a bit sharper i'm sure i could read
0.338 norma magnum norma magnum
is not a sort of glam grandmother it is
in fact
norma is a swedish manufacturing
ammunition manufacturing design company
and it's that's their take if you like
on a 338 magnum cartridge which is this
perfect almost perfect sweet spot
between 762 nato and 50 browning machine
gun reload there looked good except for
one
glaringly obvious flaw now i happen to
be looking in the wrong place at first
but i was still aware that the top cover
had magically passed through a
substantial part of the scope so account
has not been taken of which optical
sight you have fitted to your gun the
animation takes place regardless of that
but that reflects a very real issue in
actual use as well because if you did
fit a scope of this of these proportions
to this weapon well it won't clip
through you won't be able to open it
you'd have to take the scope off or
they'd have to be provisioned on that
mounting platform to pivot it out of the
way so i think what we're seeing here is
a not quite a freak situation this is
something you'd obviously if you were
adopting this particular configuration
you'd have to take account of it and not
issue this optic that's where the
freedom of a video game meets the harsh
reality of the military is you get what
you're issued
now this thing is a beast the gm6 lynx
which is the rifle we're talking about
here by the hungarian firm gephard the
the power level of this thing is pretty
off the scale available in 50 browning
machine gun but also 12.7 by 108 which
is the dushka machine gun round the
russian equivalent and in terms of
destructive effect we saw it used
against
what we call a technical a a
soft-skinned vehicle used in a
paramilitary context often they'll have
a machine gun on the back or a
recoilless rifle or something like that
this thing will absolutely destroy the
engine with a single shot of a vehicle
like that the bonnet provides absolutely
no protection at all but chances are
you're going to do something some
serious damage to that engine if it
doesn't stop running immediately it will
stop very soon which is really what it's
for it's not really a sniper rifle it's
primarily for disabling vehicles and
aircraft not usually aircraft in the air
not to say it couldn't be done but
that's not normally how you do it you
get them when they're not moving it's a
lot easier
so these weird looking red cartridges
and there's no particular reason why
cases ammunition would be red truly
cases ammunition the case is made up of
the propellant and so it's burned up in
the firing there's nothing to extract or
reject the fired primer gets blown out
of the front of the gun this gun's not
designed to fire cases ammunition it
would have to be a completely different
gun to fire cases ammunition even if i'm
missing something here and this is meant
to be case telescopes again the the
design change is needed you'd be looking
at a completely different gun that might
look similar appearing at those rounds i
can't it does look like there's a rim on
there so maybe this is meant to be some
super resilient propellant case material
that does have an extractor groove on it
and therefore the gun can be rechambered
for this what i will give them though is
the way it's depicted does seem
consistent with the way the real world
gun performs the ability to keep the
weapon on target as the player moves
forward we've seen with the other
machine gun in the game jumping around
all over the place this thing is staying
pretty much where you're pointing it so
there's the clear gameplay benefit of
this weapon which is also its real world
benefit the issue in the real world i
think is that it's a great machine gun
probably one of the best on the market
but the ones everyone's got right now
are probably good enough
now this is a fascinating video game gun
because it's not real i'm sure all of
you armor players are well aware of that
those of you who aren't might have
looked at it and gone is that an acr is
that an xcr is that some sort of cr that
we're looking at there
no not exactly it's an original design
by the american arms manufacturer cmmg
who are known for their ar15
variants that they i had to look this up
because i didn't know what this was they
designed it for the game but it doesn't
exist in real life i think it's a paper
gun that has been designed in
collaboration with a real world firearms
manufacturer for a video game and i
don't know of any other instance of this
happening i sort of have some mixed
feelings about this gun on the one hand
there's a sort of video game phenomenon
it's um it's quite fascinating but as a
player i think it would distract the
heck out of me to have as a sort of
standard issue a fictional firearm even
though it's very grounded in reality
they haven't pushed the envelope here
really with technology at all it is
generic in the sense of a sort of
present day
assault rifle design
right anti-tank weapons i'm much more of
a small arms person than i am light
weapons but that is the end lore the not
anymore really but a next
light anti-tank weapon this looks pretty
good and in terms of its ability to take
out that vehicle fair enough the only
slight eyebrow raise was the reload now
again i think we're looking at you don't
normally play these games from a third
person view so it's maybe a bit unfair
to critique the the external angle here
but there was a um an invisible munition
being pulled out of the backpack there
and just kind of wafted into the back
end of the the launcher so a very much a
fudged reload not having fired one of
these things i don't actually know what
the first person view ought to look like
but that looks reasonable to me this is
after all a true missile launcher it's
not um a weird hybrid like the rpg it's
not a recoilless weapon and it's not a
simpler rocket launcher either it is a
true guided missile launcher so we
actually see the missile we see its
exhaust trail in the optical sight as it
flies away so anyone that has used one
of these in the military let us know how
realistic you think it looks
okay i think the first thing i have to
get off my chest is just how terribly
wrong a long barrel p90 looks now i know
i know there's a ps90 with the long
barrel which is a
legal
thing there's no almost no real reason
no tactical reason to have the long
barrel on a p90. when you see the long
barrelled ones it's because it's a legal
slash financial issue so it's a little
it's a little straight well strange in
two ways to have this in the game at all
frankly firstly that the p90 is already
a niche weapon and in very limited
military use because it's cartridges
insufficiently powerful for for infantry
type fighting so that's reason one is it
surprised to see this in use in 20 years
in a straight up military context
especially in this open terrain that we
see here now to give the developers
credit that is reflected quite nicely in
the way the weapon performs on screen
there so that was about 300 maybe even a
bit further meters away so classical
assault rifle engagement distances
infantry rifle and the player was
struggling there even with a magnified
optic to actually make contact with the
enemy that they were shooting at that's
entirely what we'd expect we've got the
unrealism of it being in the game in
this context counterbalanced by the
realism of it being depicted really
quite well now having said that it does
have that long barrel on it which would
perhaps give you a bit more in terms of
velocity perhaps a bit more accuracy at
distance as a result but then why have
you got the long barrel on there in the
first place on what's supposed to be a
submachine gun so it's a little bit of a
conflicted one for me
it's our old friend the kalashnikov ak
in this case the akm the modernized ak
introduced in 1959 and at this point
pretty much the most common this is
probably the most detailed in-game model
of an akm i have ever seen lots of
detail there in the 3d model itself so
much so that i'm able to nitpick
tiny details like the front of the gas
block here it might
be the angle it might be me
but i don't think so this is an akm gas
block so note the ramp here
and the shape of the front the gas block
on this rifle is much more ak pattern so
the earlier version when you do this
good a job on an in-game gun this is
your reward you get nitpicked
if i wasn't looking at a front
right court of view of this thing i
would not have spotted that
the scorpion another submachine gun this
is a bit of a surprise as all submachine
guns in a military shooter are because
they are now a kind of a niche thing
this is the scorpion the czed scorpion
although the design is not an in-house
one this was designed by jan lukansky no
relation to the similarly named smaller
submachine gun slash machine pistol the
rate of fire took me aback i thought
that's far too high but having checked
no that's exactly as it's supposed to be
so i guess being a straight blowback
design without some way of slowing down
the bolt you tend to get up above the
thousand rounds per minute mark useful
for certain applications a problem for
others but in this scenario
outdoors shooting across open terrain
you want a rifle really
this thing is absolutely ridiculous
there are no two ways around it i have
reached my limit of fictional near
future military kit this is nonsense so
from the top type 115
implies china pretty much and i gather
from context that that is that there is
a chinese involvement here and
aesthetics wise as well it does look
reminiscent of chinese designs and
that's where it all goes wrong as far as
i'm concerned because we've got 6.5
caseless which doesn't exist in any
military supply train today and isn't
likely to even in 20 years time i
wouldn't have said but that's a
relatively minor issue over and under
with a 50 beowulf
firearm so you've got all the advantages
of caseless ammunition lightweight and
then about the heaviest cased ammunition
pound for pound for its effectiveness
that you could possibly have come up
with it's not even 50 bmg to give you
some sort of a under-barrel
anti-materiel capability that might have
made some sense giving you an inferior
rifle cartridge to complement your
superior rifle cartridge doesn't make a
lick of sense and as you can see here if
you suppress your upper barrel i think
that's the upper barrel your other
barrel is very loud so you've negated
the advantage of caseless and you've
negated the advantage of suppression and
you've massively negated the advantage
of a lightweight modern combat rifle
because you've chimered two guns
together i am not a fan as if you
couldn't tell
of course join us again next time on
this series if you'd like to head over
to the royal armouries youtube channel
we have some some extra content over
there and we've got links in the
description of this video for ways that
you can support the royal armouries
museum as we move into the future
thanks guys
[Music]
you